et puis chaque samedi depuis des mois
maintenant les règles sanitaires en
vigueur font l'objet de manifestations à
travers tout le pays le pass vaccinale
n'aura pas calmé la foule après avec le
rassemblement de florian philippot qui
perdure mobilisation en cours impasse
vaccinale dénoncée également par les
gilet jaune qui manifestent en ce moment
aussi contre la cherté de la vie leurs
revendications dans parle avec notre
reporter nadège abderrazak
bonjour nadège alors qu'elle est une
ambiance actuellement
mais écoutez plutôt festive à vous
l'entendez peut-être derrière moi des
filets jaunes qui qui danse qui chantent
pour rendre hommage à un de leur
camarade un qui a eu un grave accident
de la route il ya une dizaine de jours
et qui est hospitalisé à à quelques
dizaines de mètres à l'hôpital de la
salpêtrière donc au voilà c'était à
l'occasion de lui montrer leur soutien
des gilet jaune qui manifestent donc
comme chaque samedi depuis plus de trois
ans maintenant
avec les mêmes revendications et ils
demandent une baisse des prix de
l'énergie du carburant et de certaines
matières premières un qui y ont explosé
au cours des dernières années depuis
notamment le début de la crise sanitaire
il réclame la mise en place du rictus
référendum d'initiative citoyenne
ils protestent également contre
l'obligation vaccinale pour certaines
professions et contrôler le pass
vaccinale qu'ils jugent liberticide
propose l'écouté manifestante que l'on a
interrogé titanal on est évidemment
contre le pass and i ter l'augmentation
de l'essence à tous qui avait fait
sortir les gilet jaune dans la rue mais
surtout
on a un président qui nous détestent
donc on veut surtout pas qu'il soit
réélu même si c'est hélas
ce qu'on craint le plus il l'a dit lui
même il est là pour nous emmerder nous
on est là pour noircir son image il faut
qu'on a payé les charges et reste rien
et à partir du 10 du mois on n'a rien
mettre dans le frigidaire et en plus on
a des enfants c'est encore plus dur donc
c'est un monde
capitaliste qu à rêver à la fin de
course il faut créer un nouveau monde un
monde plus humanitaire et plus sociale
tout cnc espèce de chose ça qu'ils ont
mis en place dernièrement qui me font
penser un petit peu à ce qui se passe en
chine et ça fait peur quoi
et voilà c'est tout simplement ça et
c'est super important
mais en tant que tu ne sois conscient de
ça mais j'ai pas l'impression
et vous l'entendez peut-être derrière
nous faouzi lellouche et jérôme
rodrigues qui ont pris la parole pour
s'exprimer devant les manifestants aient
exprimé leur colère pourquoi et bien
parce qu ils l ont fait la demande pour
plusieurs parcours aujourd'hui pour
cette manifestation du 5 février et tous
ont été refusées par la préfecture de
police de paris s'est elle quasiment qui
est et bien donné le parcours à suivre
pour cette journée de manifestation
aujourd'hui ils sont en colère
aujourd'hui également pourquoi il vient
parce qu ils protestent contre 2,7 ont
simplement des forces de l'ordre a
aujourd'hui ce qu'on appelle communément
des techniques de la nasa qui est bien
et systématique pourra aller pour
manifestation de gilet jaune une
technique de l'année ce qui est pourtant
jugée illégale par le conseil d'état et
d'un gilet jaune aujourd'hui estime
qu'ils sont discriminés par rapport à
d'autres manifestants donc voilà malgré
tout malgré cette colère
eh bien ils continuent de manifester
alors à l'instant ils scandent des
slogans hostiles à la politique d'
emmanuel macron ils continuent de
manifester un dans la bonne humeur et
sous un soleil aujourd'hui
merci à des agents pour toutes ces
précisions